- So why did you start
performing together?
- Why not?
- Why not
is the thing I guess,
- That's a good question.
- You know I love singing with her.
I love being on stage with her,
and I had just done Annie on Broadway
and at studio.
- [Kate] Please clap.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah no, don't clap
(audience applauds)
- On Broadway, Broadway.
- So, I got, I got kinda got the bug again
to want to be on stage.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I hadn't been on stage in a long time
and there's a place called 54 Below,
which is a cabaret club.
And they said, hey, why don't you do,
assuming I have an act,
you want to do your act
for a couple of nights?
And I was like, yeah.
So I called Kate and said,
you're doing an act with me.
(Kelly laughs)
So that's how it started.
- [Kelly] She didn't ask,
- [Jane] I didn't ask,
- just told her.
- So what,
- [Kelly] You're doing this Thursday
is an act with me.
- [Jane] Right.
- And I knew that she would do it.
- [Kate] Yeah, and we're
sort of like a sister act,
like sisters from another mister.
- [Jane] Yeah.
(Jane and Kelly laugh)
- So why is your show
called Two Lost Souls?
- Well, you came to me and you said let's,
what songs should we do for our new show?
And she said, how about Two
Lost Souls from Damn Yankees?
I said, let's do that.
And I think it should
be the name of the show.
It just happened that fast.
- We are kinda like two lost souls.
- We are like two lost souls
on the highway of life.
- Yeah, yeah, right.
- Yeah.
- We got each other.
- I love the highway of life.
- We do this, I do this.
- This is how we go on the highway.
- This is my move.
(Kelly laughs)
- Three quarters of the,
- Signature, signature.
- [Kelly] There's more of that
to come at the show as well.
(Jane And Kate laughs)
- So, who messes up on stage more?
- You, but there's no such thing
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- There's no such thing
as messing up though.
- You keep,
- I, I keep it fresh.
- She keeps it fresh.
- You can see the show
three times that week,
you're going to see a little bit.
- It's going to be a little different,
but nobody really messes up, I mean,
that's what's kind of
funny about our dynamic
is she's all over the place
- [Kate] Yeah.
and I'm just like reigning her back in,
But we all sort of have this
kind of perfect agreement.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- There are no accidents.
- It works out, it works perfectly
- [Kelly] Yeah, I know, I love that.
And then, you know, each other,
so what you play off of each other
in the moment?
- [Jane] Exactly.
- I love an improv scenario.
- Oh, anytime like if I drop the ball,
I know she's right there.
- [Kelly] Yeah,
- that's so great.
- And vice versa.
- To point it out.
(Everyone laughs)
- No.
- And I can count on her for that.
- So what kind of,
and I can count on you for that.
So what kind of music do
y'all do in this show?
- [Kate] Well, we have the jazz quartet,
The Tony Guerrero Quintet plays
with us and they're amazing.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- They're kind of throwback to the
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, please clap,
- [Kelly] I love that.
- late fifties, early sixties.
That sort of very specific vibe,
- [Jane] Yes.
- [Kelly] And no one's doing that,
like to go see that,
- No I know, right.
- That's amazing.
- [Jane] And these guys are great.
You know, they wear the skinny ties
and the little pocket squares.
- Playing the bongos, you know,
- [Kelly And Jane] Yeah
- It's like lots of brass.
It's really fun.
- It's that late fifties, early sixties
vibe.
- A throwback.
- And our Christmas album is that too.
We've done all of your
favorite Christmas songs,
- Yeah.
- But they're in kind of a
big band, (singing notes)
- But also like "We
Three Kings" sounds like
Dave Brubeck's "Take Five".
- Mhm.
- [Kelly] I love that,
that's different.
- If that's over your head,
just look it up.
- It's different
than the norm.
- It's fun though.
- [Kelly] I love that
- And yet a throwback,
and yet it's kind of a throwback
to the Christmas albums
we all listened to over and over again.
- 100%.
- [Jane] The Bing Crosby's
- That's my favorite,
- [Jane] The Rosemary Clooney.
- Right.
- I love her.
- Yeah, I do too.
- That's my one disappointment
in life.
I never got to meet her.
- Never got to meet her.
- I actually did meet
George Clooney one time.
And I, I think
- Good enough.
- I never said anything about him.
I literally talked about his aunt
(Everyone laughs)
the entire time.
- [Jane] I bet he loved it.
- And then I walked away,
and everybody was like
you realize, you said nothing like,
Hey, you're talented.
And I was, like.
- He doesn't care.
I was like, yeah.
- I bet you he doesn't care.
- Yeah.
- He literally
just talked about
- I think he's cool with it.
Rosemary Clooney the whole time
- Yeah, he loves her.
- Sorry, George.
(audience laughs)
- Is it, is it true
that you have a section of the show
devoted to songs that make you cry?
- [Jane] Yes.
- Cause I love that.
- [Jane] Yeah.
- I love crying.
- [Kate] The stuff that made
us cry when we were kids,
specifically, which everybody
- Everybody, I'm sure
has a song that made them cry
when they were kids, mine
was "Puff the Magic Dragon."
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- I used to just,
it broke my little heart when Jackie Paper
came no more.
- Oh my God.
- [Jane] So we all got
together including the band,
and we came up with them like a Ben,
Michael Jackson's Ben,
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- He ain't heavy, he's my brother.
Seasons in the sun,
and yours is what, tell us.
- Well.
- You ruined the whole thing.
(Kelly laughs)
- You ruined the vibe.
- Mine's Tora, Laura, Laura.
- [Jane] Which is sweet,
- I'm so Irish you guys, I can't I can't.
- But then what does it
break into?
- If you're representing.
- It breaks into Roll out the Barrel.
- Then she can't help herself
♪ Roll out the barrel. ♪
(everyone laughs)
- [Jane] And she kills the vibe.
- And she kills the vibe.
- Do you have a song that made you cry
when you were a little kid?
- Oh, I don't know that I had a song,
for some reason "The Rose" made me real.
I didn't even know.
- Know what it was about
so much.
- I didn't even know what
it was about.
- By Bette Midler?
- Yes.
- It's so funny.
- And I listened to that
and it
- Such an aching song.
- It was like the song that
everybody sang in talent shows.
- Totally.
- And I was like, God, this
is the saddest song ever.
- [Kate] It really is
- [Jane] Yeah.
- Yeah, that one made me cry
- What a buzz kill.
Don't do that song you guys
- A lot of things make me cry.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I like crying.
- I do too.
- Yeah no, I,
- It's a good release.
- It's a good escape.
- It's solid escape
- It's cheaper than drinking
too.
- Yeah.
It is cheaper than drinking.
- Eric Clapton,
- It is cheaper.
- No hangover.
- Eric Clapton's "Tears in heaven".
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh,
wait, that's a good one.
- I'm like, I am on my knees melting.
- That is a good one.
- "Sussudio" by Phil Collins.
- No.
(Kelly laughs)
- ♪ Su-Sussudio ♪
- That's not a cry song.
- [Kate And Jane] ♪ Oh Oh Ooh ♪
- No.
- [Kelly] Look at her,
she's like I'm touched.
So wait, have you always
been musical Jane?
- Well, I, you know, I like to sing.
I come from a family that likes to sing
we're Irish Catholic
too, but not as Irish,
not as like drunk Irish
Catholic, you know, at the bar.
(audience laughs)
- We,
- Thank you.
(audience laughs)
- We love to sing around
the piano at Christmas.
- [Kelly] Oh that's.
- We always had a big
Christmas Eve where, you know,
the neighbors would come,
our friends would come,
the parents would come and we'd all sing.
I grew up, I'm gonna make
a little announcement.
I grew up on Funny Girl
and I'm going to be doing
it on Broadway you guys.
- Oh My God, oh my God.
(audience applauds)
- That's my favorite musical.
- Me too.
- I know.
- Me too I grew up with that.
I'm playing Rosie Brice.
Beanie Feldstein is doing Fanny Brice.
- [Kelly] Oh My gosh.
- So, I'm thrilled.
(audience claps)
- Yeah you're so excited
aren't you?
- I'm so excited about that.
- Yeah, good.
- Oh, that's my,
that was my first movie musical
I ever saw.
- Me too.
- [Kate] Wow.
- So, What about you?
You've been musical like your whole life?
- Yes. I wanted to be in,
I wanted to be in the musical Annie,
when they were first
doing the touring company
in like 1978 or something,
my mother would not let me.
And I'm so glad she waited because,
that she made me wait,
because I feel like you
don't want to peak too soon,
you know?
(Kelly laughs)
- Seriously.
- Like many in high school.
- It's true, it's true, I
really thank her so much, I do.
Because I feel so much more secure.
Also I didn't get The
Office until I was 40.
I was still waiting
tables, I'm just saying,
you know what I mean?
- We all waited tables before our break.
- [Kate] I'm a late bloomer, it's true.
Yeah, I'm proud to, I'm
like the poster child
for hang in there.
- [Kelly] I love that though.
It's not only, it's just it's,
you know, it's what you're meant to do.
- [Kate] It's true.
- And that's the thing
it's like, just hold out.
- It's true, but
- that perfect
thing's coming up.
- My mom wouldn't let me
have voice lessons because
she said you already have
piano and you already have tap.
Your sister only has
swimming, like I'm tapped out.
So she said,
- [Kelly] It's expensive.
- if you want to do it, get a job.
So I worked at a Chinese
restaurant one night a week.
My older sister worked there and I,
I was like bussing tables
and putting together
the takeout.
- To pay for
your singing lessons?
- Yeah.
- We need to thank this
Chinese restaurant.
- I'm so touched,
the gumption.
- Fu Nan in Ardmore,
Pennsylvania.
- The gumption
this kid had, you showed
up at like a talent show,
didn't you?
- Yes.
- Tell us just real quick.
Cause we're out
- Oh Jesus,
we're so out of time.
- No, no I wanna hear it.
- No, I sang with my, like
I had my piano teacher
play for me.
I was in a variety show,
it was in this club.
The first time I had
no business doing this,
but I sang like a bunch
of Judy Garland songs
and I was telling jokes in
between, didn't even plan.
I was like,
I had an act before it.
- How old were you?
- I was 15.
- She's so,
- I was was so hard on myself.
- That's bold
for 15.
- She is of show.
- And then I didn't do it again
for another year.
- This one is of show,
and that's why I love her.
- So you're going to
be performing in a bit.
I'm very excited.
So what song are you doing?
- We're doing "Far From the Home I Love".
And this is the first thing we ever
sang together.
- Yes.
You brought it to me, tell them
about the Barry sisters.
- It's a ballad
from Fiddler on the Roof
but we don't do it like a ballad.
- Nope.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, it's
inappropriate, I love it.
- It's the Barry sisters who were on,
they were a sister act.
- They used to sing in Yiddish.
- And they sang on the Ed Sullivan show
and it's just the most
perfect fun, crazy rant.
Early sixties brass, crazy bongo drums.
(Jane imitates bongos)
- Yeah.
- It's a fun ride.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- It's not a hostage
situation you guys, relax.
- Calm down.